[Music]
you guys know what crypto punks are yes
were they the first big ft right what do
you know about i'm gonna act like i
don't so you can explain it for the
audience
oh [ __ ] i have to google it then no uh
so cr so crypto punks is like it was one
of the first ethereum meditations right
and like
there's a lot of uh art so i'll just
show you
it looks like my nine-year-old nephew
made it yeah they're even before the
board apes right this is before board
apes for sure this is like the first
ethereum nft how much are those guys
like a million i think was the record 69
million for one trade
69 i didn't know that one millionaire
oh yeah for the blue face boy yeah i
know you're talking about that like
alien two i think is this yeah there was
like a video of him like actually like
crying and stuff after like the cellar
yeah so um punks have been sold for a
ridiculous amount right so like some of
them have gone for like 20 to 30 million
which is crazy is there an owner of all
the punks you're not wrong to ask that
right so
one of the people
who was just about to do a self of ease
um
release of 104 crypto punks
he and he took an 8.32 million dollar
loan backed by the same blockchain based
collectibles so he's taking out a
collateralized loan he's like saying
like hey um all these entities are worth
this much can i take it alone against
them and they're like sure so the bees
meaning like the the luxury auction yeah
exactly are they doing anything yeah
yeah yeah because this was facilitated
by these cats
and because there was enough faith there
where he could just release all this
stuff he also felt safe enough to go you
know what i actually don't feel good
about this right now like i don't want
to put my 104 crypto punks out i want to
pull them back
but he took an 8.32 million dollar loan
um off of them right
so then
the group which were first acquired
together in a single transaction by the
cat right which have an estimated
estimated value of 20 million to 30
million dollars from sotheby's that's
what sotheby's estimates right not just
some [ __ ]
um he pulled his lot his lot of nfd's
100 whatever
minutes before the sale was slated to
begin at sotheby's shocking everyone in
the room
at the time because everyone was there
to maybe bid on those right what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] wasting everyone's time
and he started to look for a way to
retain his crypto punk exposure while
simultaneously unlocking liquidity so he
was starting to see
holy [ __ ] i could borrow against these
but
um i might have to sell some of them why
would i do that if i can borrow against
them and they're so valuable like
uniformly in the crypto space so that's
kind of what [ __ ] everyone who's
trying to buy this over is that there's
so much utility behind
the name crypto punks early so you could
basically rent against your pawning
basically your own while you hold it
it's like a rolex yeah you take it to a
pawn shop
you hand to the guy and you say i want
to get this back and he's like sure give
me payments of xyz in the next
36 months and you can get it back or
sooner
so so that's what happened right so it's
a it's a jpeg version of what we all
experience in our real life economy
which blows people's minds right
so crypto bucks currently have a floor
price of 231 000
each
or approximately 68 ethereum
um which is a [ __ ] amount compared like
when i
you know when i first started buying 30
that's nothing it's really not that much
but a [ __ ] it's a mother [ __ ] i
said what about a [ __ ] so um the
demand for entities after he loans keeps
on soaring and this testimony to the
fundamental value borrowers and lenders
described to nfds as a new asset class
here here to stay says stephen young the
founder and ceo of nft
phi
um
and so this just gives you an idea of
like
okay you could just get rid of that now
or you could see it as like a new asset
class where you could borrow against it
basically finance a house finance a
[ __ ] business
like all these opportunities are there
afforded to you or you sell it and you
don't have that opportunity available to
you as easily so it's different
you have to go to the traditional fiat
means you have to like go to a bank and
say like here's all my collateral i hope
you take my loan this is all different
so
that's why he pulled
out his um collateral he was like you
know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] i think i could
do better elsewhere uh which is
different than normal thinking so that's
why this is such an interesting article
where people are like
holy such a large scale too
which is crazy it's crazy bro because
traditionally like let's say if you had
a house or something and you wanted to
start something then you would take a
loan against your house or whatever or
if you had like equity and then you like
want to remodel the kitchen like that's
like the most common thing what happens
if you can't pay for your house bar they
take it away
it's the same as your nft but it's like
isn't that less of a pain point like
isn't that much less of a pain point so
it's like cool it's not a real world
considered item it's like this
blockchain space thing so
awesome i can borrow against it and it
well the worst case scenario they it's
locked up in a smart contract they take
it from me
it's theirs now
uh it doesn't affect my life or like
anything you have to do with my family
yeah that is pretty wild you're just
like
uh i'm going to take out a loan
on this nft i'm going to buy this house
suddenly for whatever reason you don't
have enough money to pay for the house
so they take your nft away
and it's already in your house yeah well
give me a break wonderful i paid it off
but then you don't have an nft anymore
oh you're right you should have gave up
the house
joe always just breaks through with
something i'm like i didn't think of
that right
yeah because what's the point of living
then i mean you guys got to cut the fat
when you think yeah there's a lot of
noise you call us fat no there's extra
weight okay sorry you got to get
straight to the point
you do this and you're going to lose
your crypto pump
you're going to lose the picture of a
pet rock you're going to lose
that official nba michael jordan dunk
card made into the nft form
and it sounds better than the pet rock
but i'm honest i'm biased
i love the last dance i loved it it was
a great documentary there is a huge
world of
nfts right pictures on the internet that
you exclusively own and if you [ __ ]
do this and you can't pay back your
bills
all that [ __ ] is gone yeah that's
mind-blowing dude i i wouldn't be able
to live with myself if you lost your
nfts hell yeah dude that's why i don't
i'm too scared to own any you shouldn't
live with yourself afterwards yeah
i mean you could take my car yeah
take my girl
good for you but then the end of keys
that's crazy
that is mind-blowing that anyone would
give up their mfts i agree you didn't
trade your girlfriend if she's right
hell yeah bar do you have any of these
nope why
why i don't own any money he spent it
all on his house
but nobody's an idiot actually got real
houses
nobody believes you would you pay for
the house with cash [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] [ __ ] losing
six percent a year yeah you actually got
a [ __ ]
loan from the military when you could if
i got a loan for the nft i took i took a
loan against my wife if i don't pay it
they take my wife away sounds like a
good deal if you ask me
hey
yeah we're a bunch of cool boys here
we're a bunch of cool guys oh yeah yeah
in case you didn't get it ryan now the
jokes make sense i think that's how i
know you guys are cool original cuck
porn started really where they're like
the landlord's [ __ ] my wife well it's
because you put her up for oxygen
because you don't got no nfts yeah did
you just call it
cookbook is that like a adapter
the genre of like the guy sitting on the
couch he's like oh no my wife is getting
[ __ ] and he's going by the landlord no
oh no my wife is getting so pounded for
like 40 minutes
oh no i thought she would stop by now
it's been 39 minutes he's enjoying it
too much
suddenly i'm jacking off yeah yeah what
is up with that i haven't heard about
that that's weird you don't hear it
really weird
nobody says that that's so odd
that was ryan's idea yeah patented so
yeah anyway uh
it's basically just a dunk video where
it's like you know i have a lot of nfts
and you probably don't how many do you
have 150 100 holy [ __ ]
i have a lot of these you probably don't
yeah i don't know how to crypto i got to
be more like steve dude you don't have
any assets you joe you just have fiat i
have five crypto that's not i got five
how many nfts do you have anthony me
probably like
15 20. i don't know what's a good
starter maybe 30. you're 30. what's a
good starter nft experience how much do
you really want to know yeah for
longevity yeah galactic punks honestly
yeah how much do those run or derby
stars there's like 40 minutes therapy
starts every star is like seven lunar
right now six lunar right now how about
a dragon eggs one of those [ __ ]
dragon eggs yeah it's so expensive the
meteorites yeah i spent like twenty five
thousand dollars
how about the lunar whales the luna
whales
much cheaper
i spent three loonies but like that's i
guess like a lot of money now but
there's nothing there remember the
[ __ ] matrix one anthony put us on and
then i was so excited you cats were in
there for like 18 hours and i was me and
nicki were moving that day and i was
like
god damn it nikki why'd you have to move
today and she's like what's going on and
like matrix nft drops is going to
[ __ ] change their lives and like
nothing happened yeah it was weak but
then when they dropped it was the worst
[ __ ] selection
what made it bad the [ __ ] characters
the androgynous characters
it's just a guy with a blue shirt and
another guy with a red shirt bro dudes
and chicks wearing pant suits that's the
problem with it everybody's in dresses
as [ __ ] but nobody in the matrix wears a
dress though it was like 2002 sims thank
you oh
like but he loves sims yeah but not the
2000s right the 2010 sims guy yeah yeah
he was in the final fantasy back then
crying his eyes out about it that's true
still crying from 2001 to 2002. he had a
year of my pain right there it's either
that or 911 and i chose right
and there was no neo
or [ __ ] any of them the [ __ ] no
carrie anne moss i wanted nairobi and
[ __ ] so it was all just like fictitious
like characters that weren't appearing
in the films no dude i wanted to vomit
why does it even have to be matrix did
you guys play end of the matrix by the
way which was a great game
so jada was in the game and like the cat
who played ghost was in the game
and like the best part about the game is
that everybody got to take turns with
jada pinkett smith which was [ __ ]
epic oh cool like wait is that that
turns at the
boss level at that age like i never
really got to see chicks [ __ ] and
then tupac comes out
and sticks his dick inside and they he
throat [ __ ] her so him and ghost
are [ __ ] her and then tank comes in
he starts [ __ ] her he's the operator
too the operator he's got the headset
and everything exactly where are you are
you serious and at the end neo goes and
then he [ __ ] dodges the combat takes
shoots and he [ __ ] comes and then he
comes back and he's like whoa this
sounds like a new grounds cartoon two
crowns man oh [ __ ] that's actually just
what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you